our mansion's new demands a sign that
this spending bill may not be dead
former white house deputy chief of staff
karl rove joins me now
carl i got to tell you the news is not
really news right i mean this is what
this is what senator manchin was talking
about this whole time with respect to
the child child care tax credit
is anything else changed there
i don't think so i mean it's it sounds
to me like you know what's he going to
say no i'm never going to be open to
having discussions with you i don't
think that's his style and he doesn't
want to look like the bad guy so of
course he's saying i'll be happy to sit
down with you but he's been very clear
he doesn't want he does not believe we
need a big spending bill he thinks that
any measure ought to be tied to work
requirements and ought to be
also uh tied to income that is to say uh
the the wealthier you are the less
likely you are to get the benefit and if
you do get the benefit you have to be
working or looking for work he doesn't
want to undo that connection between a
government benefit and a work
requirement that so many democrats
apparently want to ask you know what's
really amazing about the whole uh part
about the eligibility up to two hundred
thousand and where it starts to phase
out up to four hundred thousand you're
still getting something
this has been promoted everything that
democrats promote they promote either as
helping black and brown or poor and
middle class but so many of these things
that they've drawn a line in the sand
with whether it's 15 000 for electric
vehicles whether it's 80 000 for for you
know for your mortgage tax or even
something like this this is not this is
not for poor folks this is something
that i'm shocked more democrats aren't
pushing back on
well they like some democrats have grown
enamored with the idea of universal
benefits that is to say it shouldn't
matter whether you make a lot or not
you ought to get the benefit from the
government because the government can
deliver it more efficiently than can the
marketplace take a look for example at
uh
at paid family leave
they want to pay
90 to 100 of the cost of existing paid
leave programs being offered by private
businesses does that make sense we're
going to have the government step in and
pay for something that a lot of
businesses are willing now to provide
their employees in order to attract and
keep a strong workforce you know this
whole idea of universality is if we can
get everybody hooked on to a government
benefit then more more power will be in
the hands of the government and less
hands in the marketplace but the problem
with that we saw in real time last year
and we're still finally now it's the i
word inflation everyone's talking about
it senator joe manchin connected the
dots hey if you give out two trillion
dollars in money that we do not need
guess what's going to happen people are
going to spend it it's going to trickle
up you're going to have hundreds of
ships parked off the ports in california
because you've ordered so many things
from from china and he knows this he's
made that connection how do how does a a
moderate a reasonable democrat push back
against that
well they shouldn't because as we also
know if you know what we're doing is
inflating the currency what we're
essentially doing is devaluing the
dollar and so the money that we get
that's one of the reasons why as
inflation has gone up even though wages
are rising the cost of the goods and
services we're trying to buy are rising
faster than our wages so the we're we're
running faster in order to get further
behind and
that's one of the arguments that manchin
made we can't afford this as a country
all this excess spending has a real life
implication and that real life
implication is it drives up prices by
depreciating the value of the currency
now having said all of these things do
you think ultimately some sort of deal
will be made
well i wouldn't be surprised if they
arrived at something but that something
would be significantly less than the
five trillion dollar true cost of the
buildback better plan it would be
something that
mansion insists be tied to a work
requirement that it be means tested so
that it doesn't go to wealthy people and
that it be quote paid for that is to say
there has to be a tax or some kind of
change that allows the revenue to pay
for the full cost of the package i i can
see them coming up with something i
don't see it passing because to to the
degree that they give into manchester
demands you're going to have people like
paypal the congresswoman who leads the
progressive caucus saying we're not
going to vote for that when it comes to
the house because we want a universal
benefit we don't want it to be limited
and we think it ought to be much much
much much bigger yeah i guess no corn
husker kickback in this one i got a
minute to go carl uh
we also heard chad uh talking about this
uh filibuster an attempt maybe i guess a
one-time adjustment to the filibuster
for voting's right
the the update on the voting's right act
what's happening there
well you've got two people cinema of
arizona and manchin of west virginia and
probably others in the caucus democratic
caucus who are not happy about the idea
of getting rid of the 60 vote
requirement because they recognize if
that happens the nature of the senate
changes dramatically and we suddenly
find ourselves in a place where if a
party controls the house the senate and
the white house it does dramatic things
and then when it loses control and the
other party gets in we ping pong back
the other direction does anybody think
that if republicans if the if the 60
vote requirement goes away and
republicans control the house the senate
and the white house they wouldn't do
things like impose a national voter id
requirement on quote voting rights i
mean
let's not kid ourselves this is a very
bad maneuver i don't know why schumer is
doing it because he doesn't have the
votes to pull it off and he's going to
look foolish come up short and look weak
as a result because he's got at least
two democrats cinema and manchin saying
we're not going for it and i suspect
from my conversation with a number of
the members of the senate there are more
democrats back there who don't who agree
with cinema and mansion more than they
agree with schumer on this yeah they
just don't want to be beaten up by the
mainstream media which has gone to town
on cinema oh my goodness the things they
said about her this weekend uh i got to
tell you carl it's great seeing you
happy new year and the framers had some
pretty good notions about the tyranny of
the majority uh human nature sometimes
you've got to protect against it no
matter how good your intentions are see
you soon friend
thank you sir hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else